Darmanin's France has become the country where
Benzema's only crime is to be called Karim.
Madam Prime Minister,
all human lives are worth Please,
please, please,
we must draw the courage of peace,
Madam Prime Minister.
Our tears cannot be of variable geometry and geography.
Thus,
we mourn the victims of the atrocious war crimes of Hamas,
just as we mourn the thousands of deaths of the war crimes committed by the
Israeli government Madam Prime Minister,
you have chosen to abandon the historical position of France which has made
its greatness and which has allowed it to be Odile in the darkness of international
relations France is now pointing the finger in the world
and by the people This must stop.
France in the past please sees a little silence and in your hands.
Becoming a state aligned,
aligned with the United States and the Israeli government,
go to war With the far right,
yes,
the far right,
this is who you give your unconditional support
to And beware of those who will not.
Thus,
the footballer Karim Benzema would be 1 dangerous extremist
in connection with the Muslim brothers.
Pursuing Darmanin Fact grave,
one speaks about the stripping of his Nationality,
his wrong.
1 tweet of support for the women and children
of Castel Please my dear colleagues.
1 little silence.
Darmanin's France has become the country where
Benzema's only crime is to be called Karim.
Madam Prime Minister,
realize that only in France there is solidarity with the people who have
been bombed for 14 days and criminalized.